this is every damn day have you ever
woken up and all your friends are
talking about that big dick energy
sometimes it happens it happened to me
when I looked on Twitter and it's
because ariana grande alluded to the
fact that her new fiance Pete Davidson
has a big penis and so people are going
crazy about it they're using the phrase
big dick energy I don't know what's
going on guys what does it mean what
does big dick energy mean I was raised
to have big dick confidence that's what
we was told as kids you know my friends
we talk about having big dick confidence
all the time you gotta walk into a room
like you got a big dick you don't have
to have one but you gotta walk in there
like you got you got a head of
confidence of a big dick energy just
means confidence don't know what big
digging into you this new shoes I think
big dick energy was defined by the
person who like did the tweet that got
big as like someone who is very
confident like they have a big dick but
not necessarily like boasting about it
they're just quietly confident as a
person energy I think things like vibe
yeah - show that you have a big dick but
you're like I feel like I have yes
confirmation of big dick energy you
don't have to show it you have to elude
it yeah I would say I'm more of like a
show or than a grow why don't we just
say confidence it's different it's it's
a conf it's like when someone with like
teeth is like I'm gonna buy you a drink
they have a huge day
[Laughter]
[Applause]
special notes everybody with tip just
start buying drink your whole world will
change
I have a question is big dick energy
gendered or could women have big dick
energy as well you mean big clit energy
once a woman with a big clit I don't
know I think they're I think they're
still talking in terms of energy it's
like strong vagina energy that strong
vagina she can give birth to big ideas
but without tearing her ass so Donald
does Donald Trump have big dick energy
because he's always like I'm so smart
I'm a simple genius
big dick energy is like people just know
it Obama huge dick I'm great I'm people
just like a musician thing yeah our show
is still a political yes we could be lib
tux or we could be Naga Nazis listen no
[Laughter]
I think Donald Trump has dragon energy
which is a new energy there are energies
going on there's big dick energy there's
dragon energy which is Kanye's energy
which i think is like a dragon breathing
fire saying I'm a dragon look at me I
think that's what so is our world right
now kind of a clash between big-dick
energy and dragon energy comes to a head
yep licking the throne which will win
you know song a big dick energy yep
I think
but don't you think if a dragon had big
dick energy you'd be breathing lots of
fire we are right here right now the dry
sad that is creepy
that's more like smog just sitting on
all his gold coins need to go burn down
a cap hashtag dragon energy big dick
energy no flames do you think you got a
big dick energy oh yeah what's everyone
what's everyone's energy in the room
what type of energy do we all know
something that other people say you have
yeah because if you are like I have big
dick energy you immediately yeah you got
that then you got the little dick energy
yeah what if you claimed little dick
energy so that way the room can say you
got big Dickens yeah I have micropenis
energy so you're stuck at my go dig
energy aren't for me belittle with his
dick energy do I get hired did that
lowers your - we both got my dick you
know I don't have any dick energy yeah
man just tired carrying around this huge
[Applause]
we're gonna do another thing right now -
you got to get it down that's the key
these are big shots just three just
three I'll take you know I mean how's it
happen he's got to get the last one down
that's the worst one he knows mentally
do anything hey everybody this is a
segment called who is drunk and we've
got a special guest it's Tim Robinson
from Comedy Central's Detroiter we're
gonna show you some photos from these
five people's social media presents
mm-hmm and all you got to do is deduce
if they are drunk in the photo okay and
I get asked any question I want about
the photo how many one three oh wait as
many as you want you can't just make up
rules
Aynsley let's do the first photo oh we
got shoeless look at wrist this is a
Wawa parking lot
oh okay gas station parking lot why did
you take your shoes off my feet were
sweaty sweaty and you took socks off -
and you don't notice whatever that green
litter is next to you yeah I want to say
you're drunk
stone sober
long drive and then I got a sandwich
took your shoes off in a gas station
parking lot sober were you crying you
look like you can cry well I mean that
we already answered the drunk question
let's go oh that's that's true I don't
know what beer that could be very first
beer and no sips what time is this eight
o'clock in night bar or like somebody's
basement it was a bar and we were about
to start a comedy show we're about to
start a comedy show I'm gonna say
because of like that kind of like real
wet wall back there yeah it's soaking
wet which can't be good for the
mechanics of that track moist moist I'm
gonna say you are for sure drunk in that
oh yeah I was drunk I was spectacular
but I was drunk okay he's not a row like
oh I'm gonna say nhadra I think that
feels to like you you wouldn't do that
when you're drunk I think that I think
you wouldn't dress like the mask if you
were drunk our discussion topic was big
dick energy according to the Pichet
chris is taking it very literal you got
that big bulge and he got a halter he
does we can say bold we can say this but
we can't do this oh yeah you're right we
can't say you're
okay but you don't point at me while
you're doing that that was our
interpretation of the S&T Road we might
not be quite right I don't think you
were pointing oh okay Wow kind of artsy
really artsy is that alcohol yeah that's
a beer and there's two other beers going
into the beer to describe this is like a
magic eye where are you
Brooklyn Brewery you took the phone you
can see both of your hands did no those
are my friends oh that's the trick
there's three hands I'm holding the beer
two hands coming in that's the cool part
of the floor they cropped it I didn't
you hold two beers and have your friend
take the photo that's that's that's like
normal as hell I'm asking us a normal
cell dude really bull what what is that
it's a lot involved but this is a cool
t-shirt I mean this show has a bully we
should have warned you Jude that's
pretty drunk
he's our bully drunk in this photo or
not uh no it's true
I just started drinking Wow not drunk I
wouldn't like that night my first drink
was oh yeah that's my first drink ever
oh my god
all right Aynsley next murder in what
time lunch time 1:00 p.m.
lunch time and that's a corn dog with
ketchup
dog seems like a drunk choice I like
that hat a lot of real lot I'm gonna say
you are drunk here ending on a correct
one but Tim guess what that was just the
pregame sir
the real game starts now one of you is
drunk right now
Tim secretly before we started taping
one of these people took three shots of
tequila based on the interactions you
just had and any further questions you
would like to ask who do you think is
drunk in the room somebody was a bully
could it be a mean drunk
it was tequila I think a nice brand of
tequila oh he listen upper so I don't
think I didn't mean
[Laughter]
actually wait you think everybody's a
boat is that your cat sure you gotta ask
the audience or like call a friend like
I've got a mad audience thing right here
like for real dude I'm sure for you cuz
like it's embarrassing if you're wrong
season two trainers design now
comedy central Thursdays at 10:30 check
it out
[Applause]
[Music]
you